something we can all relate to is the
endless supply of healthy foods that are
being thrown our way and whole foods is
now taking it to a whole new level they
are going to be building a whole foods
spa in austin texas you're gonna be able
to go there for days and get all your
fancy food and your kin wha and your
give me a fancy food somebody you're
healthy families asparagus that was a
good one yeah and you're gonna get
massages in detox and the whole thing so
what I want to bring to you guys is how
important is the food culture to you
because I know for me it's like if I go
to trader joes I feel like I have
somehow bettered myself then go into the
regular store but how important is just
the food and the process of getting food
and all that to you I mean it's
incredibly important you know I I to
feel healthier and better when I go to
whole foods and trader joes you know I
feel like I'm making a difference for my
body and self however i must say I don't
know if I'd want to attend a spa that is
whole foods ran like I've heard of like
farm to table eating but this seems like
a farm to toilet eating like I should
just have a direct to of going in my
mouth and out my ass and it's like no I
kind of like to keep my massages and
like my you know asparagus separate I
don't know I and also what I don't
understand is this concept that you know
they've been doing these classes and
things like that and seminars and
they've actually been failing miserably
so I don't understand how they've
actually said we are going to take this
failing model and we are going to charge
a lot of money for it I know it's been
free so far but we're actually gonna
charge and first of all I can't even get
to the damn parking lot in los angeles
cuz they're so busy how the hell you
gonna get through a resort in austin
texas that's gonna be another nightmare
I mean look I I you know sometimes I go
to whole foods to eat and sometimes i go
to look it's like some of the creatures
walking around in there or as foreign as
the food on the you know it been a great
salad i think i think it's cool but I
mean it's like I don't know would you
guys I don't know that I might
it's cool like I mean I here actually
have a class they stick a tube in your
mouth that's right it's a cleansing no I
think it's awesome I think I would love
to go to I love that kind of stuff
though so I mean that's me personally
and I know what the guy i think in LA I
think a lot of health oriented people
would do that but I think they want to
gear it towards more obese people i'm
assuming it's nothing so when i was
reading the article i kept thinking are
they gearing this to help the obese
people slim down but i feel like the
obese people they know what they're
doing to themselves you know what I mean
everyone knows what you're putting it in
your body so I think this is just going
to be the ultra healthy just getting
ultra healthier although is it just me
or did the ultra healthy never look that
good when you go to like the the vegans
section of their of the supermarket they
always look like they need a piece of
meat don't they look green a little
[ __ ] you want to feed these we freedom
I agree everyone needs a steak I agree
the skinny people are the ones that need
a burger yeah yeah well we'll end this
one on this question if I was going on a
vacation personally I want to go to a
beach I want to get wasted maybe smoke a
little bit a bit of what we're gonna
talk about in the next story you know I
don't need to be getting healthier I
don't need to be getting healthier on my
vacations does this idea so I know this
idea doesn't appeal to this healthier on
a vacation I don't know it totally
appeals me I actually like you know
going on it I like to call it there's a
difference as vacations and then there's
retreats like if I'm going on a retreat
I like to come back feeling better about
myself vacation I like to just wallow in
my own regret you know but but really no
i think i'd be interested in checking it
out you know it can't hurt and i think
i'll come back with a cleaner colon
right clear yeah my healthy caches or
healthy vacation or bus man i'm all
about it I mean literally I like to
usually go get wasted and on the beach
were never like that by David healthy
vacation or wasted madness uh healthy
but I'd want to drink and eat and you
know be sloppy while I was there wait
fair enough
don't forget the official outfitter of
the Reuben report is bonobos calm enter
code TR are 20 for twenty percent off
your next shirt